three to five million illegals voted for
Hillary Clinton people went from
Massachusetts to New Hampshire to vote
for crooked Hillary Kris Kobach voter
suppressor in chief is gonna figure it
all out we were told as part of a voter
fraud commission and then we would learn
once and for all that it was actually
Donald Trump who won the popular vote
against Hillary Clinton or not Donald
Trump has disbanded that bogus laughable
pointless voter fraud commission that he
started so sad right they were doing
such good work on that commission why is
it being canceled because too many US
states have decided they're just not
going to cooperate with Trump's
witch-hunt check this out
despite substantial evidence of voter
fraud set up presidential Trump a
presidential statement from Donald Trump
couple days ago despite substantial
evidence of voter fraud many states have
refused to provide the presidential
Advisory Commission on election
integrity with basic information
relevant to its inquiry rather than
engage in endless legal battles at
taxpayer expense today I signed an
executive order to dissolve the
Commission is trump forgetting about the
entire thing not really he says that now
the Department of Homeland Security
should look into it instead oh yeah I'm
sure they're gonna get right on that
right Kris Kobach who was running the
thing says that this is not a victory
for Democrats because with the special
Commission Democrats could have had a
seat at the table but now that the
Department of Homeland Security is going
to be dealing with it it's just
Trump's DHS running it and Dems are out
well that kind of ignores that there's
nothing to find I mean all along this
was just going to be a pretext to
further suppress the vote and sure Trump
is going to try to push the Department
of Homeland Security to come up with
something that justifies even more
oppressive voter suppression tactics but
that was going to happen with the voter
fraud commission as well but there is
another really interesting angle to this
which is a Steve Bannon angle over the
last couple shows we've been covering
the growing feud I guess we would call
it between former White House
propagandist chief Pett Steve Bannon
and White House and the White House and
the White House is reportedly trying to
distance themselves from anything that
Steve Bannon was involved in or at least
that they're attributing to him and
someone who's familiar a source familiar
with this voter integrity commission
said quote Steve Bannon was immensely
focused on the voter fraud Commission
another person familiar with the voter
fraud joke is what I call it said it was
a quote blundered Bannon roll out that
quote never should have been in place do
we believe that right I mean you can't
really have it both ways on the one hand
Donald Trump has been saying Bannon
never influenced me in any way he was a
minor player in the administration but
at the same time you have White House
officials speaking on the condition of
anonymity saying the entire voter fraud
thing was just Bannon ban and ban and
Bannon when it was a major focus for
Donald Trump publicly in fact the three
to five million voted illegally and
ominous to try to figure out what
happened was one of the earliest decrees
that Donald Trump said when he was
elected Frette president if Trump never
had any influence how is it that
something as major as Trump made this
out to be was bannon's idea it doesn't
really make sense to me and I don't know
how Trump is will justify it maybe
they'll say well Trump's got the deep
state blocking everything he's doing
they want illegals voting for Hillary so
of course they're gonna make sure that
the voter fraud Commission fails you
need some pretty significant cognitive
dissonance to believe that and the other
thing that I noticed when I was
researching the story is that I saw
comments online saying liberals are
cheering the disbanding of the voter
fraud commission because liberals want
illegal votes to be cast no liberals and
conservatives who are rational are
cheering because this was a major waste
of taxpayer money based only on Donald
Trump's fabrication that three to five
million people voted illegally for
Hillary Clinton as a basis for
suppressing the vote in the future
anybody who is understanding of the
reality should be glad that this is over
if you're on the left
be glad that it's over because it was a
witch-hunt to suppress the vote if
you're on the right you should be glad
that this is over if you're a so-called
fiscal conservative because this was
just a waste of taxpayer money to fix a
problem that doesn't exist which is
in-person voter fraud everybody should
be glad that this is over and yet this
is part of the evidence that there is
some shadow force that is preventing
Donald Trump from really uncovering the
truth which is laughable at this point
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show follow
me there